depuis 15 ans il est très connu pour le
rôle de José évidemment on vient de voir
les images dans la mini-série préférée
des Français scènes de ménage ne dis pas
que c'est la tienne parce que tu en as
entendu oui je sais pas après tu te
mangeras après sur les côtés de Valérie
Karsenti qu'on a vu aussi à l'image qui
joue Liliane votre épouse vient de
regarder un couple de quinquagénaire
toujours très amoureux faut quand même
le dire d'ailleurs ça rappelle un peu la
pièce avec ses armes dont on va parler
merci oui bien sûr enfin Cédric vous
connaissez pas on va en parler avec
César et on va en parler allez on parle
de troupes le très amoureux vous êtes à
Marie un peu bene et très attachant
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce qui fait
rire
et drôle mais oui moi je fais tout allez
Frédéric on regarde les images je veux
tout moi ici
oui bon ah tu permets
quand même
en face alors maintenant l'idée que Tata
Odette s'y installe franchement j'ai
hâte qui se termine pour voir ça oui bon
ça va on va pas en parler jusqu'à demain
quand tu es digital Noma tu peux
travailler n'importe où dans le monde on
est d'accord tu vas travailler dans le
quartier toi
ben non
[Musique]
alors ça évidemment on va en parler à
Frédéric mais c'est l'évoquer justement
pour savoir comment vous êtes passé au
théâtre en fait vous avez démarré au
théâtre j'ai vu ça je le sais et dans
des pièces Molières Pinter vous avez
tout fait Shakespeare et tout ça il
faudrait qu'on regarde justement la
bande-annonce de le teaser en tout cas
de AB César parce que c'est à l'affiche
regardez ah oui c'est ça
[Musique]
donnez un surnom à vos parties intimes
tu l'appellerai comment toi alors
[Musique]
on est bien non on va pas en faire une
salade César
[Musique]
attends attends attends attends attends
attends attends
[Applaudissements]
bravo ça a l'air délirant ça aussi ouais
c'est une pièce assez extraordinaire
pour nous à jouer parce que ce qui est
merveilleux c'est tous les soirs les
gens nous disent on a beaucoup courir on
a pleuré aussi parce que ça parle de
couple il y a de quoi pleurer aussi des
fois dans l'histoire de couple et la
pièce est magnifique parce que il y a
toutes les émotions à jouer et c'est
très très fort
un peu dans le couple on parle pas tous
en même temps merci beaucoup chers
non ils veulent pimenter le couple alors
ils inventent des trucs etc et César si
vous voyez la pièce vous allez voir ce
que c'est César c'est quelque chose de
très précis chez vous chez nous
on a compris
j'ai vraiment perdu un peu parfois un
peu parfois alors dites-moi Frédéric
bouralie comment on fait pour passer
justement d'une identité très forte avec
cette série qui est une des plus
regardée en France pour aller au théâtre
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
facilement ou est-ce que c'est vous qui
êtes allé demander parce que je sais
comment le métier difficile et que quand
on est comme ça catalogué c'est très dur
et d'ailleurs Shirley va nous en parler
aussi j'ai la chance de par rapport à ce
déménage qui est qui est prévu mais le
jazz s'est déménage moi je trouve que
deux jours par mois c'est déjà très peu
donc c'est formidable parce que ça me
laisse la le temps pour faire plein
d'autres choses dans du théâtre moi j'ai
du théâtre que vous disiez tout à
l'heure donc c'est vrai qu'on propose
beaucoup de pièces c'est vrai je je
touche du bois j'ai beaucoup de chance
j'en suis très heureux et cette pièce là
particulièrement m'a beaucoup plu
vraiment et puis ma caméra Cristiano
brute super actrice de théâtre
magnifique actrice elle va jouer
Bérénice bientôt elle vient jouer le
vieux dans le donjon c'est une grande
actrice de théâtre et on se prend un
pied tous les soirs assez grand Bérénice
c'est racine bien sûr et ça sera au
cette notoriété effectivement très forte
vous avez hésité au départ ou pas vous
pensiez pas que ça allait être un succès
aussi considérant mais parce que
justement ça bloque souvent les acteurs
dès que tu as un gros succès quelque
part les gens te laissent dans une
catégorie c'est vrai oui mais oui mais
je suis assez gâté parce que vous savez
ça déménage pour moi c'est un casting
comme un autre moment je le fais puis je
pouvais pas imaginer de ce succès
personne peut l'imaginer moi à ce moment
là je tournais d'autres trucs je faisais
plein de choses d'ailleurs je me
souviens très bien que la première fois
que moi appelé j'ai fait le casting j'ai
oublié le casting j'ai fait un call ce
qu'on appelle un call back tire il faut
revenir une deuxième fois et quand ils
m'ont rappelé j'ai dit excusez-moi je
suis plus de quoi vous parlez
maintenant j'en ris maintenant j'assure
qu'elle est à l'époque c'est vrai c'est
un casting comme un autre puis après
quand vous faites ça vous pouvez pas
mais même Nicolas tes Vernon
il pensait pas qu'on ferait un succès
pareil il pense que ça marcherait mais à
ce point là c'est lui si longtemps c'est
lui ouais et donc c'est merveilleux quoi
c'est des aventures absolument
extraordinaires puis ma caméra je suis
assez gâtée parce que
on se connaît très très bien et
Cristiano rebouche vous gâté quoi
comment il vous appelle les gens dans la
rue José José Frédéric les deux
objectifs pardon la plus célèbre
réplique de scènes de ménage qui est
identifié par les téléspectateurs c'est
Liliane qui dit à José tu as vu José je
me suis fait un gommage et lui il répond
raté on ne voit encore
bien joué Charlie Bousquet Charlie
Bousquet toi c'est pareil tout le monde
te connaît depuis Caméra Café en fait
hein c'est un Nancy voilà et puis tu en
as fait pas mal on a tourné enfin moi
j'ai pris
le soleil mais pas de scène ensemble
c'est dommage mais beaucoup de séries il
y a eu oh
le soleil et ouais
[Musique]
mais dis-moi alors toutes ces séries que
tu as enchaîné tu en as fait beaucoup
puis il y a eu aussi la Bernard Academy
à côté de Florence c'était son premier
truc à la télé en fait
exprès
40 ans en arrière là on voit mon âge
pardon Caméra Café
aussi là on vient de oui on a fait 20
ans après
il manque d'ailleurs le psy et voilà
c'est le seul
justement comme je disais je demandais à
Frédéric comme ça tu es catalogué bon tu
as fait aussi beaucoup de cinéma
c'est la télé qui m'a emmené au cinéma
et ça quand même c'est plutôt c'était à
l'époque très nouveau et c'est vrai le
film de Caméra Café qui m'a ouvert les
portes du cinéma et après j'ai fait
l'amour c'est mieux à deux de Dominique
Farrugia et Arnaud le mort avec Manu
Payet Clovis Cornillac plantable et tout
ça donc moi je suis enfin je trouve que
voilà c'est un peu la télé qui m'a amené
au cinéma
tu as senti Charlie que tu as été quand
même catalogué à un moment quand on fait
la télé comme ça aussi fortement
c'est-à-dire que ça marche ça cartonne
on s'est dit c'est une actrice télé oui
elle non mais toute façon on est
toujours catalogué moi j'ai commencé ma
carrière en faisant des pubs des pubs
télé et on m'a dit oh là là tu fais des
pubs télé
mais j'ai fait j'ai essayé le comté j'ai
fait obligé
j'étais un peu fleurée je cueillais des
des fleurs c'est pour ça qu'il est
unique bon bref
j'ai fait tout de suite
j'en ai fait mais j'en faisais plein
dans un une coupure pub je pouvais être
sur plusieurs pubs brune blonde enfin
j'arrêtais de changer bref et on me
disait c'est mort ça fait trop de pubs
tu feras jamais télé bon j'ai eu la
chance j'ai fait de la télé on me dit tu
as fait de la télé toi une série ah non
mais c'est mort tu feras jamais de
cinéma bon bah voilà et puis maintenant
ça a beaucoup changé les gens de cinéma
sont de la télé enfin ça s'est démarré
depuis 2019 voilà maintenant je suis
aussi Laetitia je suis très soleil
bravo tous les deux Sophie quand même un
petit changement à un moment donné aussi
que vous avez justement pris à ce
moment-là c'est le moment où il y avait
aussi Jean Dujardin Alexandra lassuy
avec chouchou loulou etc où il y a eu
ensuite Kaamelott ou toutes ces séries
finalement ont quand même créé des ponts
avec le site alors bien sûr le pont d'or
pour du jardin bien sûr il a ouvert
de dingue bien sûr mais vraiment il y a
eu quand même des ponts à ce moment-là
qui se sont faits où on a commencé à
avoir une considération même pour les
séries parce qu'en fait il y avait une
écriture
sans parler de Virginie Efira ouais
alors là
c'est magnifique aujourd'hui
quand on a des acteurs et qu'on a du
talent les réalisateurs de cinéma
connaissent la difficulté de tourner
dans une quotidienne la rigueur les
acteurs doivent être ils enchaînent donc
aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout un
problème de passer de la télé quand on
est dans une série quotidienne c'est une
plus-value tant que vous avez du talent
et certains écrivent se mettent à la
réalisation donc c'est je pense que tu
as raison en revanche Gérard Vives vous
vous rappelez lui il regrette
dans un rôle mais c'est normal
il y avait il avait son texte il y avait
pas de texte le personnage n'était pas
intéressant on pouvait pas tellement
s'identifier c'était difficile pour lui
dire mais je suis d'accord avec Rachel
en revanche c'est toujours plus facile à
l'heure actuelle pour un acteur de
cinéma de faire de la télévision bien
sûr
du cinéma
on lui déconseille de continuer à faire
de la télé ça a été le cas pour du
jardin ça a été le cas pour Jamel
Debbouze qui lui est maintenant fait ce
qu'il veut mais donc il y a toujours un
espèce de snobisme du cinéma envers la
télé
mais les ponts sont quand même possible
on m'a dit ne va pas dans le théâtre
privé j'y suis allé je suis très heureux
on m'a dit de toute façon
le privé tu feras pas de cinéma j'ai
fait du cinéma je les emmerde tous après
on m'a dit si tu fais du cinéma va pas à
la télé je fais la télé je suis très
heureux donc
nous empêcher des trucs oui parce que
Frédéric vous en avez fait beaucoup de
choses quand même moi je vois j'ai noté
modestie va souffrir allez le cinéma
du mot qui
Molière au théâtre Musset etc vous ça va
c'est bien
c'est ce qui est magique aussi dans ce
métier c'est qu'il y a des périodes où
ça peut être des creux et puis du jour
au lendemain ça redevient la folie il y
a même Gabin à l'époque il y a eu 10 ans
où il a rien fait et puis après c'est
une guerrière
exactement
pour faire une comédie j'ai toujours et
j'en suis ravi enfin
évidemment je suis pas contre mais c'est
très rarement on m'appelle très rarement
pour faire de la comédie c'est rigolo je
suis drôle ça
je pense que on peut quand même dire
qu'à part certaines exceptions c'est à
dire que là ça a l'air d'être le cas
pour vous et c'est quand même le cas
pour certains et pour certains grands
acteurs français qui ont réussi à faire
la diff quand même j'ai l'impression que
c'est quand même un piège la série
surtout qu'au moment où justement tu vas
passer ton casting tu sais jamais si ça
va fonctionner temporaire tu es intermé
les exemples par exemple de tous les
gens ont pas réussi à citer tous les
gens qui
j'ai une question est-ce que vous
cherchez encore à intégrer des rôles où
on vous attendez qu'on vous appelle
moi j'attends toujours qu'on me proposer
zéro et puis il y a des rôles qui
arrivent et que j'accepte sans passer
d'essai tout tout est encore
est-ce que vous allez peut-être essayer
de vous incruster dans le film si on
vous a pas forcément
[Musique]
Shirley le problème
non c'est une question de nature ça il y
a des gens et c'est très bien il y a des
gens qui savent faire ça
très bien Jean-Michel on a une carrière
comme Fred est-ce qu'on passe encore des
casting ou est-ce qu'on
reste encore des questions et c'est pas
vous acceptez c'est ça c'est vrai
je suis obligé de faire mes preuves vous
aimez les castings j'adore ça ouais
parce que c'est une manière de
rencontrer le réalisateur c'est le
premier contact réalisateur et c'est
super et vous avez pas génial je crois
qu'on a un trade particulier lors des
castings sur les
castings à l'époque où j'étais une
grande star du cinéma
il faut accepter ce qu'on est
c'est-à-dire que faut pas faire plaisir
aux acteurs ou penser j'ai appris depuis
bien j'ai le sens là m'a aussi aidé à ça
j'ai appris que au casting il faut
assumer ce qu'on veut ce qu'on propose
c'est ça que parce que j'ai été de
l'autre côté aussi j'ai fait passer des
castings aussi donc je sais ce que c'est
je sais que souvent que la personne qui
rentre dans la salle on sait que c'est
celle-là qui ont on va prendre on sait
pas jouer et vous savez justement on n'a
pas vouloir ça a aucun rapport avec le
talent parce qu'en général les gens qui
passent ce casting c'est des gens on va
pas demander
si tous ces gens qui ont du talent et
équivalent à peu près c'est pas question
de talentualité la personnalité faut pas
tricher faut y aller mais derrière
qu'est-ce que vous avez raté des rôles
justement à cause notoriété je rentrais
d'autres ah oui oui bien sûr
mais c'est là métier on peut pas j'en ai
c'est vrai que j'ai de la chance de
réussir beaucoup mais
j'en ai raté aussi et je rater d'autres
et c'est normal
on va juste dire un tout petit là c'est
que on fait une opération avec la
Fondation avec son enfance tous les ans
qui s'appelle action enfance cinéma et
il a accepté ils sont pas si nombreux
les stars à accepter de jouer avec des
enfants placés toute une journée dans un
village avec Alice Belaïdi merci
bravo Frédéric
et toi Shirley est-ce que tu as pensé
aussi de t'as raté des rôles à cause de
cette grande notoriété que tu as à la
télé aussi oui bien sûr parce que
parfois ils aiment bien découvrir un
nouveau visage et que du coup bah toi tu
es trop assimilé Caméra Café oui on le
sent très vite bon
quelle était la plus vilaine réflexion
que n'ai pu te faire
vous avez joué Bernard Montier
avec José Dayan grande réalisatrice
merci
[Musique]
rien j'ai des petits rôles rigolos j'ai
fait les campings j'ai fait
des petits trucs
[Rires]
alors Shirley ma chérie dis-moi est-ce
que tu as vu comme ils sont avec moi
alors quelle est la plus mauvais en tout
cas carrément en face on t'a dit non
ouais toi tu es gentil un si grand
soleil Caméra Café tout ça ça va quoi
une fois il y a un producteur qui
m'appelle pour une pour une pour une
série et il me dit bon alors a priori
bon voilà tu serais bien pour ce rôle et
tout mais quand même tu joues souvent
des méchants donc moi pas des gens
méchants
je veux que des gens sympas donc si tu
es méchante moi ça m'intéresse pas
je suis sympa mais c'était bizarre que
quelqu'un m'a professionnelle
mais disent un truc pareil justement
tous ces rôles là parce que c'est vrai
que vous jouez tout le temps des relevés
et est-ce que c'est vous qui avez envie
de jouer ou c'est ou c'est ce qu'on va
alors au début non je pense que c'est un
physique
non vous disiez quand même dans la rue
dans le métro les gens parfois vous dis
mais pourquoi vous êtes aussi ah bah oui
à l'époque oui oui bah je sais pas il
doit y avoir dans mon physique une
espèce d'autorité je crois que c'est les
yeux ou je sais pas moi vieillissant je
je
suis sympa
Frédéric est-ce que le public qui vient
pouvoir au théâtre c'est ceux qui vous
regardez dans qui vous regardent donc
dans scène de ménages ou est-ce que ça
c'est un nouveau public ce qui va
à Paris c'est c'est varié il y a une
partie de partie des gens qui me
connaissent à la télé bien sûr vu à la
télé voilà mais et puis très vite sur la
pièce de toute façon ça il se rend
compte que c'est pas du tout le et en
province un peu plus je sais pas
pourquoi c'est normal moi des
compliments moins complexé à dire ce
genre de choses
en tout cas les gens me le disent et on
va partir en 3D spectacle je suis ravi
je voulais en tournée
c'est bien la série télé ça amène du
monde aussi au théâtre
les gens mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
vous mettez Frédéric bourali et ta Rahim
dans la rue tarahim sera très grand
acteur et je l'aime beaucoup mais tout
le monde reconnaîtra Frédéric Bouraly
vous en avez énormément qui ne
reconnaitront pas time c'est le côté un
peu plus populaire qui touche un peu à
tout le monde et absolument tout le
monde le connaît qui vient de démarrer
cette semaine le film Monsieur Aznavour
réalisé par Grand Corps Malade
incroyable étonnant vous avez une photo
non avec qui avec
taraïde peut-être on verra on verra
qu'avant il y avait un certain snobisme
par rapport aux séries télé et que
depuis qu'il y a les plateformes
cités
c'est aussi du cinéma il y a des grosses
productions il y a beaucoup d'argent je
il y a des gros acteurs donc il y a
beaucoup moins de snomismes et on peut
plus faire ce pont oui enfin maintenant
c'est devenu le Graal aussi oui oui
c'est plutôt en fait cinéma mais
maintenant presque on veut notre série
sur Netflix
c'est toujours ce qui après qui arrive
je sais pas j'ai plein d'autres projets
au théâtre là en vrai c'est que ça se
fasse j'ai un joli projet avec Denis
Lavant
on a un projet tous les deux là au
théâtre à bientôt bravo ouais ça fait
partie des
choses puis mon rêve en fait c'est de
garder mes amis ah ça c'est bien et il
est sage en tout cas on vous retrouve au
théâtre dans la pièce avec César Théâtre
Rive Gauche avec Christelle Reboul du
mercredi ou dimanche à Paris une comédie
de Michel Rémy mise en scène
oui c'est ça
et toi ma Charlie on te retrouve soleil
projet cinéma projet cinéma non
prochainement avec toi en 2024 bah
écoute avec joie et puis le retour de
Caméra Café